a de nouveau frappé à zaporigia en
Ukraine en pleine nuit une pluie
domicile s'est abattue sur des quartiers
résidentiels faisant au moins une
vingtaine de morts et des dizaines de
blessés évidemment c'est un bilan
provisoire comme vous le voyez les
recherches poursuivent je joins notre
envoyé spécial en Ukraine Marie-Ève
Bédard Marie-Ève qui a vécuse Moscou de
vouloir se venger après avoir encaissé
de Lourdes revers des pertes importantes
notamment avec cette attaque hier contre
le pont de Crimée
une attaque qui n'a toujours pas été
officiellement revendiquée par l'Ukraine
mais on craignait une réaction forte une
réaction vive de Moscou elle n'a pas
tardé au cours de la nuit vous l'avez
dit une pluie de missile qui s'est
abattue sur un édifice ou des centaines
de gens Bitcoin édifices d'appartements
assez élevés mais dans des quartiers
résidentiels aussi ou de toute petite
maison assez modestes en briques ont été
complètement soufflées par cette série
d'explosion les recherches ont commencé
dès cette nuit dès les premières
explosions pour les habitants ça a été
une nuit de cauchemars ceux qui ont
survécu à l'attaque on cherchait à se
mettre à l'abri mais cherche pour
beaucoup toujours des leurres le
président va le dire zeninski n'a pas
tardé à réagir sur les réseaux sociaux
il a fait une déclaration et je vous le
cite il a dit que c'est le mal absolu ce
sont des terroristes et des sauvages de
celui qui a donné cet ordre jusqu'à
celui qui l'a exécuté tous sont
responsables devant la loi et le peuple
et pour les gens donc qui attendent
toujours des nouvelles de leurs proches
ce sont des moments interminables
d'angoisse je vous propose d'écouter
une femme qui a passé cette nuit qui a
été réveillé par le tremblement des
explosions et qui avait pu sortir de
l'édifice
sur le pont de Crimée hier et bien
Vladimir Poutine accuse l'Ukraine d'en
être responsable c'est la première
réaction officielle de la Russie du
président de Vladimir Poutine qui
rencontrait le comité d'enquête qui se
penche sur les causes de l'explosion sur
le pont qui relie la Russie à la Crimée
il a accusé donc les services spéciaux
les Forces Spéciales ukrainiennes donne
attentat qu'il a qualifié lui aussi de
terroriste selon la Russie c'est un
camion bourré d'explosif qui aurait fait
exploser ensuite ce train qui contenait
des citernes avec du pétrole mais cela
dit la circulation est déjà ouverte
partiellement sur le pont l'enquête se
poursuit et la Russie promet de faire
payer les responsables mariage Bédard a
créé en Ukraine merci
au revoir